je voudrais vous faire remontrer pour
une juive sur ce petit écran qui est là
un très court film sur l'un de nos
invités qui est joseph joffo c'est
dominique resnick off qui est allé le
rencontrer à paris dans son salon de
coiffure
parce qu'il faut bien reconnaître que
s'écrit à des talents c'est que vous
êtes un coiffeur
auteur de belles maisons c'est quand
même assez rare d'avoir un coiffeur qui
est aussi un best-seller seul yves le
sac de billes s'est vendu à combien
d'exemplaires
si ce que me dit mon éditeur est prêt je
pense qu'il a aucun intérêt à conter des
histoires il nous avons vendu environ
650 mille exemplaires est ce que vous
vous rendez vous que c'est vraiment
phénoménal dans l'édition à huy sagement
en compte parce que quand ce livre est
sorti je pensais qu'on allait frère à
tout casser
5000 10000 exemplaires entre les gens
qui me connaissent mes clients mes amis
disons qu'elle estime seddoukois et
alors ça c'est pas que ça irait au delà
ce livre raconte l'histoire très très
touchant de deux enfants qui sont donc
deux petits juifs qui sont persécutés et
qui sent bon pendant la guerre tous les
deux tout seul bravement avec 5000
francs en poche et traverse toute la
france et ses deux petits juifs c'est
vous et votre frère exactement ses jours
alors comment ça vous est venue l'idée
d'écrire cette histoire est ce qu'elle
est vraie elle est vraie 150 % disaient
mais de toute façon je pense que quand
on a vécu une histoire comme celle-là on
a envie de la raconter et plus je
pensait certainement pas comme ça allait
faire un best seller je pensais que
c'était c'était un petit je me suis peu
plaisir en écrivant alors il y à joseph
joueront donc vous qui avez écrit ce
livre il y avait maurice notre petit
garçon qu'est-il devenu
ah ça c'est une excellente question ans
a choisi est une question très
intéressante première fois comme la
pause et bien maurice et mon associé au
corps aujourd'hui ainsi que maison
propre frère nous avons monté
ce mode est à vous pas que vous voyez là
entre autres y en a encore quelques uns
à paris deux ou trois en province dont
cuba ça va ces unités d'artistes vous
voyez les artistes associés il ya un
personnage que l'on voit pas beaucoup
avec eux très présent par par les
enfants eux-mêmes c'est la maman
qu'est-elle devenue eh bien madame en
bavent sénat et lcp
un modèle de mon prochain livre est elle
à 87 ou 88 ans on sait pas exactement
parce que à l'époque dans ces villages
or ici pour les déclarer deux ou trois
ans plus tard console quand les parents
allaient à la ville et j'y allais
rarement ont déclaré les enfants qui
étaient nés
et un peu dans l'inconnu mais elle est
là elle tient le coup et je touche du
bois c'est non joie pour moi d'avoir ma
mère je pense que quand on a sa mère en
est tout jeune
bien sûr c'est pour être finalement on
est toujours heureux par comparaison
alors il suffit simplement de se
rappeler ce que nous avons vécu pendant
la guerre et je pense qu'à partir de ce
moment là il peut plus rien nous arriver
et pas d'être heureux encore est ce que
vous croyez vraiment joseph joffo qu' il
ne peut plus rien arriver aux juifs dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui parce que vous
racontez effectivement dans à nice en or
qu'est-ce qui est l'histoire de votre
mère vient d'apprendre qu'elle est
encore vivant tout ce qui a pu arriver à
une petite fille juive russe aux
alentours de 1900 et toute cette fuite à
travers l'europe avant de venir en
france
est ce que vous vous croyez vraiment que
c'est quelque chose qui ne pourra plus
arriver à vos enfants
je l'espère en tout cas vous aspirez
vous être un succès laissez moi au moins
être optimiste mais je suis prêt je me
pose la question
enfin j'espère que les guerres de
religion sont terminés
croyez vous que votre mère par exemple
quand en 1920 après avoir été si j'ai
bien compris d'un village de russie à
eau des sacs puis en turquie puis à
vienne n'ont pu à budapest plus à vienne
puis paris
quand elle est arrivée à paris en 1920
elle a dû dire eh bien maintenant que
j'ai connu les programmes en russie et
et les persécutions dans tous les pays
de l'est et que je suis à paris il ne
pourra plus rien arrivé à mes enfants
en arrivant à paris mais d'abord elle a
eu l allure coquerel a eu un choc
formidable parce que sur le fronton des
mairies
il est gravé liberté égalité fraternité
et ça ça n'existait nulle part ailleurs
alors là il ya cru non en plus elle a eu
une chance extraordinaire
elle a rencontré mon père elle a
rencontré l'amour est en fait elle était
partie ce n'était pas le but de son
voyage paris parce que le but de tous
les exilés de l'époque c'était d'aller
aux états unis en amérique d'amérique
c'était la terre de libération c'était
quelque chose de formidable refaire
l'amérique comme le chant de bassin
c'est quelque chose de fantastique
encore de nos jours et elle était partie
pour aller aux états unis et s'est
arrêté à paris elle a rencontré l'amour
est là elle a dit je suis arrivé donc je
lis accrue est s'est installé en france
sa famille
c'était le but du voyage c'était la fin
du voyage c'est presque un lieu commun
de le dire mais en tout cas peut-être
thoune aux téléspectateurs le saf style
- coeur que vous que nous il semble que
le destin du peuple juif soit d'être
constamment comment dit on
en voyage
[Musique]